the south korean government eased covet
19 restrictions less than a month ago
but on wednesday officials say they may
consider reimposing some rules
the number of new cases and seriously
ill patients is rising across the
country daily infections reached a
record four thousand one hundred on
tuesday and nearly seventy percent of
beds in intensive care units are now
occupied
a major factor that has contributed to
the increasing number of cases and that
has made the hospital bed utilization
rate a bit worse is the increasing
number of infections in the elderly
senior citizens were the first to be
inoculated earlier this year and health
officials say part of the reason
infections are rising is because their
immunity is waning
the government says it will give them
booster shots what the government is
trying to do at this point is to
expand the deployment of booster shots
especially among the most vulnerable
as quickly as possible they're
increasing testing especially in
congregate residential settings such as
nursing homes and
long-term care facilities
officials are also conducting test and
trace operations after more than 200
people tested positive for covet 19 at a
church in the city of cheonan
in the morning the central disaster and
safety countermeasure headquarters
reported that around 91.4 percent of the
confirmed cases from shonen were
unvaccinated
the increase in infections so soon after
restrictions were lifted will be a blow
to many but although the numbers rising
there's some relief that at about 35 a
day the number of deaths remains
relatively low
florence louis al jazeera